if you don't know what's important to
you what kind of work you want to do
what you want your life to look like you
end up defaulting to one of two things
what pays most or what are other people
doing you can end up very far from what
you actually want and you'll only know
that when you get there so you have to
have a very clear sense of like where
you're trying to go or these things
these opportunities are chances to get
super off track
you've got this quote that I referenced
a couple of weeks ago be quiet work hard
and stay healthy it's not ambition or
skill that is going to set you apart but
sanity yeah what's that uh well I find
uh as a former like sort of young person
going places
that when I I'm hiring someone or I'm
looking for someone like that could I
want to like Mentor help or whatever
it's not like how talented you are or
what your background is but it's like
the first test is like
instead of fine is like is this person
[ __ ] nuts or not you know what I mean
like does this person have their [ __ ]
together or not and so I think
we often think a lot about like getting
better at what we do like the craft of
the thing which is really important but
then when you look at like why did this
person make it and this person not make
it it's usually you know
very some Stark Divergence where they
started making bad decisions they you
know started being very egotistical they
had this shot and they blew it you know
it's not it's not like in sports where
you're like this guy's just faster than
that person it's some other thing that
usually
sort of prevents a person from reaching
everything they're capable of reaching
is there an element in there as well
about playing a long game yeah for sure
for sure definitely I mean one of the
hard Parts about having sort of
potential and ambition is that it burns
sort of very hot and bright
and you know if what you if you want to
be established you want to do it for a
long time
you have to figure out how
you had to play a long game to not blow
yourself up to not it's like how do you
care about it very deeply but not sweat
it so much that it's like a liability
needs to be sustainable man yeah yeah I
I play with this all the time and a lot
of the guys that I see that have
flashing upon successes on the internet
are very similar
yeah well look and we live in an
environment where algorithmically you
can just be given a huge gift you can
just sort of blow up right and so
that really has nothing to do with
whether you deserve it or not but then
once you have it the question is can you
maintain it can you do the work
necessary can you not [ __ ] it up right
and I think we I when I talk to
groups I usually start with some version
of like
you know like the biggest enemy in this
room is not like what the other people
are doing it's not the economy it's not
like Gatekeepers like the person who
determines like how this is gonna go is
you really like for the most part most
failures are self-inflicted or most big
mistakes are self-inflicted and they
often come like right after some form of
success that's kind of the most
dangerous Point that's a we overread
since when we go it goes to our head
that's when we you know it's like it's
in that moment of success or Triumph or
whatever that like you need the most
discipline but there is the highest
justification for
slacking on said discipline right so
this is that's where it happens there's
a quote from Charlie Munger that says it
is remarkable how much long-term
Advantage People Like Us have gotten by
trying to be consistently not stupid
instead of trying to be very intelligent
yeah that's right yeah it's it's like uh
can I not blow this up like I remember
so like I dropped out of college when I
was 19 or 20. I sort of had all these
cool opportunities very early like
things that especially with what was
happening because I I sort of left right
in the financial crisis so all my
friends are struggling sort of watched
as you know people my age have taken
longer than you would expect to get
where they want to go and then so I was
very cognizant of the concept of like a
regression to the mean right and so just
because you break out early just because
you have this thing you know
statistically
you're gonna end up like everyone else
so you have to be really cognizant of if
that's what Ten's gonna if that's what
would happen sort of naturally you
better make sure you don't accelerate
that process like there's even less room
for self-inflicted or you know
unnecessary errors so I I was like
really in my 20s I was thinking a lot
about like okay you've gotten these like
opportunities you have this stuff like
the number one thing is like don't [ __ ]
it up
how do you avoid being too risk-averse
when that happens yeah I don't know I
mean that that is the tension like you
you you still want to take big swings
but it wasn't like it wasn't like I was
risk averse in the sense of like I don't
want to like I've got this capital and I
have to protect it it was more like how
do you not
alienate the wrong people how do you not
you know take your foot off the gas at
the wrong time like it was more like ego
complacency uh entitlement you know like
the uh those kinds of you know like
feeling like you're anointed feeling
like you're special like as soon as you
start thinking like the rules don't
apply like I've made it I'm good like
that's when you know you're probably
getting into dangerous territory yes it
seems to me that ever since James
Cleveland's book Atomic habits this has
been something everyone's thinking about
right that your outcomes are a lagging
measure of your inputs like where you're
at is just a lagging measure of the
things that you've gone toward that and
it seems like discipline is pretty much
exactly the same and that's where the
I'm gonna guess the line between your
future Destiny is dictated by your
current discipline what I was thinking
about that actually just recently like
all the work that I when I'm working on
a book so discipline just came out I'm
working on the next one like all the
material real in those books are the
result of research writing thinking
organizing that I did a year ago five
years ago 10 years ago right and so all
all the work that you'll do in the
future is in a sense the dependent on
the work that you're doing now and how
long you continue to do it and so like
when I sit down I'm sitting down and
writing today the the material that's uh
available is like you said a lagging
indicator of work that I did at some
unknown previous date and so it can be
really easy to be like consumed with
what the task is in front of you and
that but if you're not simultaneously
also setting up
the future stuff you're gonna wake up
one day and you're not going to have
what you need it's like you can and I
think the better you are the more
momentum you have the easier it is to
Coast first a long enough time that you
don't even know that the foundation is
being eroded from underneath you yeah
yeah it's a bank account that you pay
into every single day yes yeah it's very
interesting to think about that I I
going back to what we said at the very
beginning about people being able to
blow up overnight yeah uh I did a
reality TV show called love island in
the UK a little while ago and that
basically plucks people out of obscurity
and gives them two million followers and
a million pound contract with a fast
fashion company and they're the hottest
thing in the world in the UK pretty much
every single person knows who they are
and I have been worried for quite a
while about what that teaches young
people about the route towards success
sure not that you're supposed to do
something that's very difficult at a
high quality consistently for a long
period of time despite what the market
says to you yes it's that you're
supposed to be in the right place at the
right time yeah I mean uh one of the
amazing things about the internet is
that it's this platform they'll it's so
much more democratic it's so so many
more people get their shots but then
then you get that shot and
you still have to like have the stuff
right like you can you can get like you
can have one thing go viral you can have
one thing but like can you consistently
or repeatedly do it do you actually have
like once you have the audience do you
do you have the stuff and I'll see this
too like someone will be really good on
one platform like they have a podcast
that does well or a YouTube channel that
does well or you know the social media
account and then uh what happens is like
you know the entertainment sort of
business is like well we want you to do
this we want to do this and like so I
often interact with those people when
they're coming to do a book and you go
oh like you're really just a feature or
a function of the medium you're in you
don't actually have like there's no
there there as the expression goes like
you don't have like a core thing that
can then be translated into the other
mediums if you have that your your
golden like you can you can succeed in
all the different Platforms in all the
different ways if you have some like
unique point of view or a voice or a you
know a thing that you a message that
you're delivering you know it doesn't
matter if you start on this platform or
that platform you should be able to with
some skill and hard work be able to
translate in all these different ways
and be able to succeed in a sort of
multi-disciplinary
format the problem is if you're really
just like right place right time then it
comes time to do this thing and like the
audience just feels that there's like
there's nothing there
um
something that I found very interesting
thinking about discipline was the
relationship between
directionality or an outcome that
discipline is being filtered through it
feels like you need something to direct
your discipline toward without a
direction discipline is pretty hard to
deploy because what are you being
disciplined in service of what does
discipline even look like you know as an
ex-club promoter for a long time what
was disciplined to me going out until
four in the morning sure maybe somebody
else's idea of complete destruction
that's true yeah it what what is the
outcome where you're trying to get
what's it all being directed towards
that's sort of the ultimate question
like you know
practice without some aim is not really
practice at all it's just activity so
yeah you have to figure out what it is
that you're trying to do like for me it
was you know okay I don't want to write
that's what I want to do so then it
became clearer like you know what are
the
composite tasks that go into being in a
position to do that just like if you're
like hey I want to run for office you
know okay maybe military service would
be helpful you're going to graduate from
these schools you have to cultivate this
network if this there's a there's a
resume that you need to have that job
right and you got to know what that is
that's not to say that everyone has to
do it the same way but you got to know
the sort of the The Collection or the
portfolio of assets or tools or skills
that you're that where you want to end
up but the Stokes have this line they go
like um
if you don't know what port you're
sailing towards no wind is favorable you
have to know where you want to go and
this is this is really true like even
for successful people like if you don't
know
what where your stopping point is what
you want your life to look like now all
of a sudden you know you're in this
wonderful fortunate position where
people like hey you want to do this you
want to do this they're offering me this
you know do you want to take this amount
of money to do this or more money to do
this and you know if you don't know like
what's important to you what kind of
work you want to do what you want your
life to look like you end up defaulting
to one of two things like what pays most
or what are other people doing
and those are not the worst proxies in
the world like it's better than no proxy
but you can end up very far from what
you actually want and you'll only know
that when you get there so you have to
have a very clear sense of like where
you're trying to go or these things are
these opportunities are you know really
chances to get super off track
with that in mind is it easier to be
disciplined before success arrives
well I mean look it's easier to say like
singularly focused or it's you let's say
it's easier to say no to stuff when
you're not getting offered a lot right
um it's easy to be principled when the
you know there's not a lot in the way of
consequences right so all these things
are easier to a certain degree uh when
you're dealing with sort of less volume
or like lower Stakes
um I mean one of the hard Parts about
being disciplined early is that you're
doing this thing and the payoff may be
eating all of it and you know very far
lagging indicator you know so I think it
it's the truth is it's always difficult
to be disciplined right
um it's always difficult and it's
something you have to figure out how to
do and enjoy for its own sake because a
lot of times there's not only not
rewards for it but there can be the
opposite of rewards for it right like
there can be punishments for if you're
like this is what I want to do this is
the track that I'm on this is what's
important to me and you look around and
everyone's not doing those things and it
seems like they're having a better time
it seems like they're getting ahead for
it right you you have to
if the only reason you're disciplined is
that you think
what comes on the other side of it will
be worth it
not only is that going to be hard when
you're not immediately getting it but
then you find like oh I was super
disciplined until I hit the best seller
list I was super disciplined because I
wanted a gold medal a super then you get
that thing and even that thing itself
isn't the reward that you thought it was
so if you hated the process of it
you told yourself it'll all be worth it
when you know there's a there's a
disappointment there and the
accomplishment is tinged with the kind
of sadness
was there anyone that you researched for
the book that had that happen that
reached lofty Heights and then the
discipline fell away
uh I mean I think it being disciplined
once you're in the promised land is it's
an extremely difficult thing
um I don't know I mean when I when I
look at Super disciplined people I I
again I'm not just making the case like
okay you gotta sacrifice it then you get
this and then you don't have to do it
anymore it's more a kind of uh it's it
it has to get to a kind of an intrinsic
thing I remember I was uh
as talking to Lance Armstrong once and
he said uh like I raced for the money
but I practiced for me some version of
that that like his point was like he
likes riding the bike what they pay him
for was the competition right and like
and like people have obviously differing
opinions about ones are strong but he's
a person who clearly loved doing the
thing and you have to get to a point
where you love doing the thing that's
why you do it and like in writing for
instance there's writing and there's
publishing and those are not the same
thing
um like publishing is when it goes out
into the world and that's interacting
with the publisher and there's contracts
and there's deadlines and there's press
and there's good stuff but there's also
a lot that's not up to you but like the
the dated daneness of it is
is you does that make sense yes and
seeing the
stuff that you maybe aren't super super
enamored with as part of the price that
you pay the same as getting up on time
the same as hitting your word count yeah
Douglas Murray says that once the book
is published that's when the real work
begins that's how he it's just I've said
it's like a second marathon and some
people are not willing to run that
Marathon
um but like I remember I heard this
interview with a comedian once and he
was saying that like someone asked him
like are you still gonna do comedy like
once you've hit it big or you know and
his point was that like yeah of course
because if I don't it means that like I
was doing this for the wrong reasons
right that like he was a comedian as a
means to an end to do another thing like
acting or producing or you know having a
sitcom or whatever it is like
I like doing the thing that I do and I
want you'll tend to find this is why
discipline is so important as you get
successful out of something like you
know all of a sudden you're a Pro Bowl
quarterback or you're you know a CEO of
a company or you write a book well now
you have all these opportunities to do
not that thing
right like people want to pay you to do
other stuff endorsements they want to
pay you to come speak here they want you
to consult on this or invest in this and
so
if you don't love that thing
you're going to end up doing all those
other things or worse if you do love
that thing but you don't have the
discipline to be like this is what I'm
here for this is like what why I did
this you want the reward for your
discipline and your success is that you
don't have the time or bandwidth to do
that thing anymore yes and you only have
a limited window to do that thing right
and so one of the things I try I try to
go like well could other people like
writing is the thing that only I can do
like only I can write the things that I
have to say so I have to figure out a
life and a system and a practice where
I mean filtering what I'm saying yes and
no two but I'm also like Building
Systems or structures so like I'm not
spending a lot of time
doing things that are prevent and then I
don't have time to do
the hard thing which is like sit down at
the blank page
that Outsourcing of tasks that other
people can do is an important one one of
the challenges at least I'm seeing now
especially because Naval and his
Concepts around leverage and all of that
personal accountability stuff I think
people are quite quick to Outsource
stuff that they probably shouldn't be
I'm seeing a lot of uh so for instance
in the podcasting world would be a good
example
um
the podcaster is the only person that
understands the direction that they want
to take the show in but tons of shows
that are smaller than the size of this
one have guestbookers that look after
all of the guests that come on sure they
have researchers that read the book and
tell them the questions that they should
ask they have a thumbnail and a titling
guide that comes in and demonstrates how
it's visible visually going to look on
YouTube and sure and on Apple podcasts
and stuff you go well like what are you
now I have a friend who did a 330 date
Comedy Tour
over many years basically doing the same
act and he said that after the first 50
to 70 shows he was no longer a comedian
he was an actor and the point being that
he was no longer actually script doing
the art of Comedy he was just a
mouthpiece for what had happened before
and he had to take a big chunk of time
off because he'd lost his love yeah yeah
you have to maintain the authenticity of
the the craft or the thing and yeah you
you do Outsource and you you find
leverage points but it's usually about
the trivial things that don't matter yes
to free you up to spend the most time on
the things that do matter so when you're
saying no to stuff it has to be clear
that that is part of a process of saying
yes
a thousand percent yes to like the
things that really do matter so yeah
when I Outsource if I have an assistant
or if someone was my lawn or I I'm sort
of taking tasks up that's not so I can
just dick around right that's so I
really do have the time to like sweat
the details of
the stuff that I make right
um I tell the story in the book there's
this exchange um Coretta Scott King
Martin Luther King's wife is is called
by the actor uh Harry Belafonte uh and
you know she's I think Martin Luther
King had just gotten arrested or was in
a sort of a way doing this uh March or
something and as they're talking on the
phone uh
you can tell like she keeps having to
put the phone down she gets interrupted
kids are need something just take food
out of the oven she's like just busy
while they're on the phone and and
Belafonte goes like I it's a personal
question but I have to ask like
are you do you have like any staff like
are you doing are you totally by
yourself right now and she goes yes yes
of course uh and he says why don't you
have any help and she goes well you know
like my husband's a minister she thinks
the Optics are bad you know I don't know
if we can afford it it was just sort of
combination of this block that they had
and and Belafonte goes look that's
ridiculous and it ends now he's like I'm
I will pay for you to have stuff and he
realizes that like he's like they're
doing they're running this massive
organization they're the head of this
movement that has the potential to
change the world like
uh Martin Luther King can't be worried
about whether there's milk in the fridge
or not and his wife can't be you know
worried you know about this or that like
there has to you have to have the
ability to to delegate and build like a
system or a structure around you and
then and I think that can be really hard
for people especially if you came to
what you did from a very sort of Scrappy
like uh uh passionate thing where you
loved doing it one but two like you
didn't think anyone could do it as well
as you and yes and it takes a certain
amount of discipline to to to find out
what to separate the essential from the
inessential
to delegate or eliminate the inessential
and then that leaves you with the
essential in meditation the markets
realize so you can imagine he's the
Emperor of Romans having to think about
this exact thing and he says you know
the question you have to ask yourself in
every moment is is this essential and he
said um because most of what we do and
say is not essential and he says the the
thing is when you when you eliminate the
inessential you get the double benefit
of doing the essential better and so
this this isn't you know this sort of
hoity-toity like first world problem
it's it's in a a critical dilemma a
critical juncture Point as you get
better at what you do how do you find
the way to professionalize and
systematize and scale the stuff so you
can spend more time on the things that
matter and less time on the things that
don't matter or you can bring in other
people who are better than you at
certain things that allow you to take
what you do to another level
it's such a common uh Dynamic that I see
especially coming from the northeast of
England right spit and saw the salt of
the earth people who are that person
that you said Scrappy they've come up
from the bottom up they've done all of
the things themselves they were HR and
marketing and finance and accounts and
all that everything yeah and they get to
the stage where you go look man like you
are now bouncing off the rev limiter in
first gear the only way that you're
going to be able to do this is to
relinquish some of this control and it's
a combination of fear of perfectionism
of a lot of things that that come about
and it is a particular type of
discipline it I think the Puritan work
ethic this is something that I would
love to have drilled into myself 10
years ago
so we run a Saturday club night in
Newcastle the city I went to Union
and uh I did 204 Saturdays in a row
without missing a single one yeah uh the
only first one that I did miss was
because I had a chest infection and I
was completely dead I literally couldn't
go I was going on holidays that would
leave on a Sunday and get back on a
Thursday for four years because I didn't
want to be away for this particular
thing I was absolutely adamant that if I
left the Saturday something would go
wrong sure but the the stuff that I was
doing during the day setting the club up
was getting a piece of rope with a
gaffer tape and throwing it over the top
of a particular bracket at a very
specific place because that's where the
inflatable went that looked right in the
middle and if it went a little bit to
the left it was often it went a little
bit to the right and then the way the
smoke machine was set up and everything
I mean my business partner did this we
were the directors of this company that
was doing thousands and thousands of
people every single Saturday night and
it was us that was spending three hours
each Saturday between 11 and 2 going in
and doing this yeah like why well it's
because we were terrified that if
somebody else did it that would be the
gateway drug the pebble at the top of
the Avalanche that would cause
everything to Fall to Pieces look and
there's a there's a form ironically of
of kind of uh
uh fear or resistance in this sort of
obsession or you know sort of drive to
be on top of everything I remember
um when I was at American Apparel I
looked down for my office one day and
the CEO and owner of the company was in
the parking lot like directing traffic
like there'd been some problem and
there's a traffic jam and he sees it and
he runs downstairs and he's like
directing traffic like thousands of cars
it's like a shift change he's directing
traffic and so there's some you know
version of leadership stories where this
is like Hands-On the leader gets down in
the trenches with the soldiers and like
does what needs to be done and
there there is truth to that like a
leader has to be willing to do anything
but a leader also can't do everything
and the truth is there were a lot of
hard decisions that the company
desperately needed to make like
strategic decisions uh sort of cultural
decisions the ones down in the car park
that weren't down there that he was
as I step back from it can clearly see
was running from those things you know
there's the immediate reward the
immediacy the tangibleness of like I'm
gonna go solve this problem when he
should have been in his office doing
something that if someone walked by
might not have looked like work right he
could have been sitting there like this
just thinking but
if he doesn't do that no one does that
right like you have to think about your
role in an organization in a project in
a field you have to go like
um if not me then who right and like
there's a lot of decisions especially as
you get higher up that only the owner
only the creative only the main person
can make and thinking long term you know
setting principles you know setting
goals except those are the things that
only you can do other people can do a
lot of these main pieces but if it's if
you're not doing that thing it's not
happening and you have to figure out
what that is and that's what that
question is this essential is like is
this essential am I the only one that
can do it what happens if I don't do it
and that's got to sort of determine your
you know day-to-day priority list or
your to-do list so that would be
somebody not with excess discipline but
with um discipline that is heavily
focused perhaps in a sub-optimal
direction or perhaps behind them almost
it's focused on tasks that they should
have let go of a little while ago yes
what about someone on the other side of
that what about somebody that achieves
the accolades and gets to that stage and
then everything falls away I think he
had uh was it Robert Mose Moses yeah was
somebody that was like that and you
could compare him with like a George
Washington who or um who's the guy that
was in charge in 1944 when America was
in the war at George Marshall George
Marshall yeah him uh
that would be a big difference right you
have someone that's basically in charge
of was it you said about 70 million
human lives oh Eisenhower yeah yeah
Eisenhower is basically this sort of
brief moment after the second world war
the most powerful man in the world leads
this enormous Army you know he's the
head of the nuclear Arsenal you know he
is
a conqueror of conquerors the head of
you know the most powerful nation in the
world for this sort of brief moment
and he has this line that I think a lot
about he says you know freedom is better
defined as the opportunity for
self-discipline and so you know we think
of discipline as this thing you need to
achieve a kind of success right and you
do you have to be disciplined on the way
up
uh but also like people make you
discipline on the way up because you
have fewer options there is no other way
right you you have to be disciplined
about your money because you don't have
any right you have to be disciplined
about your work ethic Etc because like
you're in this competition with all
these people and sort of a forcing
function but then you get there you get
to the top and now the rules that
previously bound you or the things you
needed to prove that's not there and so
if you're not self-driven if you're not
you know enforcing that discipline on
yourself
it all falls apart right and I think
deep down the reason a lot of people are
ambitious and want to be successful is
they they have they want to be the
president or they want to be the CEO or
they want to start their own company
what they think is that the end of that
rainbow is an exemption from all the
rules that they don't like and in fact
it's those people have to be stricter
on themselves The Stokes would say no
one is fit to rule who is not first
master of themselves and so the idea is
that discipline is is not this thing
that is enforced on you like when you're
in school you can't go to the bathroom
at this time you got to be here at this
you know as you work your way up a lot
of those things not only not only Fall
Away
but actually life says well what time do
you want to be here right like what do
you want from us what do you need from
us right suddenly people are
accommodating to you and so or you know
they're building you up they're telling
you how great you if you don't have this
sort of strong internal Compass the
strong sense of what you're okay with
what you're not okay with what you need
to do what you shouldn't do then the
success is going to be deeply unmooring
right and deeply disconcerting and
liable not to last because
you it's like you ran past all the
barriers and now you're just there and
so uh yeah discipline has to be this
kind of internal thing that you
cultivate that stays with you whether
the circumstances are really good or
really bad
do you not think that this is where
Commodus would have probably played a
stark contrast to his father's role yeah
I mean what's so interesting about
antoninus Marcus Aurelius and then Mark
cyrilius's son Commodus you have sort of
a great emperor a greater Emperor and
you have one of the worst Emperors
and why is that
um I don't I mean there's so much we
don't know right we don't know what the
relationship was like we don't know what
happened it could be that Marcus
Aurelius was the greatest father in the
world and his son was a psychopath right
um we know there's a there's just a
tragedy the whole thing is tinged in
tragedy in the sense that you know
Marcus Aurelius had 12 or 13 children
and every one of his sons dies Commodus
is the only one
um we have some sense that Marcus for
instance the first thing Marcus Aurelius
does with absolute power this incredible
moment in human history he's named
Emperor and he anoints his brother his
stepbrother co-emper the first thing he
does of this Powers he shares it right
which is a nod to the old Roman system
which had two consoles like had two
presidents who would serve like
co-presidents who would serve these
one-year terms then Rome becomes an
Empire and uh and this changes but
Marcus says things that there needs to
be this kind of check on Power and so he
and his brother serve as co-equals
we get the sense that he said he was
setting up some system where two of his
sons or his son and his co-empers his
step-brother son would rule together
okay so do you think that maybe Marcus
was trying to Future proof any one
Tyrant from being in too much control
because you would always have this other
person and by doing it at the moment
that he was given power it set it was
the the highest cost that he could pay
yes like one of the most beautiful
passages in meditations against this
Prat you have the private Journal of the
emperor of Rome and and he's saying be
careful not to be caesarified you can
easily be dyed purple he says the the
Roman Emperor wears a purple cloak and
he's he's saying you can't be died
probably you can't be stained or Changed
by this position you're in right we we
have Lord Acton's rule of like absolute
power corrupts absolutely he was saying
like he he was consciously talking to
himself about trying to prevent that
from happening
and I think obviously the decision at
the very beginning to share power is
like uh you know a a very big sort of
Step like it's preemptively trying to
prevent that from happening and we we
believe that his succession plan for his
son was to set up some sort of system or
tradition where that happened again
the other Quirk is Marcus is the only
emperor of five Emperors in a row to
have a male heir
so Marcus Marcus's father is not
antonite it's Marcus antoniasis is
adopted father just as uh antoninus's
adopted father is Hadrian and Hadrian's
adopted father as trajan there's this
period there's this process so Marcus
isn't able to do that right he's not
able to choose an error because he has a
male son uh but we get the sense that he
wanted to have two maybe one his son one
of his brother's son or two of his sons
rule together
um but you know the best laid plans they
all die
and so Commodus is the only one left and
you know we don't know what Marcus
thinks of Commodus
we can imagine every father is blind to
a certain degree to the flaws of their
children and trapped by you know
the insaneness of this system
uh but certainly something goes wrong
and it's a tragedy of uh and in some
ways an indictment of Marcus right like
if you're the most disciplined you know
decent human being but
somehow you're not able to pass that
along to your family I mean what does it
say it it raises a lot of questions for
sure that is interesting the fact that
you have this
emperor philosopher god king thing going
on incredibly giving very benevolent
very caring you know was equality like
the ideas that were literally Millennia
before that time yeah
and yet one of the few roles that every
father has that they need to fulfill
somehow happened but then everybody is
so idiosyncratic and unique and
individual you don't know I mean we all
know about the rebellious rich kid that
happens to be a dick yeah that smashes
up the father's car and has parties in
the house when the parents are away and
all that stuff so and I suppose the open
loop here that may never is most likely
to never be closed unless we discover
some more hidden something somewhere
is interesting for speculation it's like
is this a blip and what would have been
otherwise a pure white snow surface of
Marcus aurelius's rule or is it just you
know the exception that proves the rule
which is the reason we don't have this
system is that it almost never produces
good results right like there's 30 or 40
Roman emperors there's five that they
consider the five good Emperors right or
does the finish that finishes with
Marcus is the last but Marcus is
considered the last the five good
Emperors there's five Emperors in the
road there's a few other good ones but
the point is I mean even with the
passing of Queen Elizabeth like how many
other good ones have there been there's
not that many there's been thousands of
kings and queens in these various
kingdoms over thousands of years and
there's probably what two dozen that
were like they did a good job they
proved what Matthew Arnold one of the
sort of biographers of Mark cerelius in
the 1800s writes who is you know Marcus
Aurelius is given every privilege and in
power and advantage in life
and the remarkable thing is he proves
himself worthy of it right and how rare
that is not just in you know royal
families but like anyone with any kind
of privilege right how many people who
are incredibly athletically gifted also
you're like and they're a great person
too right or people who are wealthy in
your life and they're also so hard
working and such a great parent right
the reality is and this is why I think
discipline is such a virtue and Justice
too and wisdom and all it it's really
hard it's really [ __ ] hard and it's
it's harder in it's harder in some ways
when you can get away with not doing
those things and that I think is what
sort of privilege and power often
enables it there's not the forcing
function of having to earn it right like
comments doesn't have to run for
election you know like he's just gets it
and because it doesn't have to get it it
doesn't do a very good job of it
that's the interesting element about
the life cycle that discipline has
especially as you progress as a human
that in the beginning it's about working
hard it's about uh leaning in as you
start to develop more and more it's
actually perhaps a little bit more about
leaning away it's about restricting the
options that you have it's about leaning
in a little bit less and that what got
you here won't get you there mentality
has never been seen more for me than
watching that kind of transition at
least begin to happen in in my life as
well I'm like look I have more things
that I need to say no to than things to
say yes to and I was a uh pathological
yeser
um so I'm like okay well what do I what
do I do now I I can't people please
anymore sure uh if I take my eye off the
ball on the main thing the main thing is
the podcast that needs to happen I need
to prepare I need to choose guests that
I'm interested in I need to make sure
that I am on my game as much as possible
that's the the single ordinating
function two examples actually that I
keep on using uh and I don't know
whether you came across them so
apparently when he was an Amazon Jeff
Bezos filtered every decision through
one heuristic and it was does this make
the customer experience better and
apparently uh Elon Musk has got the same
and it does this get us closer to Mars
and I don't know if it's true but
certainly doesn't look like he's
following said rubric
that's Up For Debate uh my point being
even if it isn't the idea you can see
how much more simple everybody's life
would become if you had a single
ordinating principle it's like does this
make the people of Rome uh the the
existence better everything from do I
have wine tonight to what time do I get
up tomorrow to who do I have meetings
with and this is where the multiplicity
of options that people have in the
modern world creates a difficulty for
discipline I think because the the
amount of distractions that are there
well that's the idea if you if you don't
know what port you're sailing towards no
wind is favorable how do you judge
whether you should do X or Y whether you
should do it now or later right whether
you should say yes or no
how much you should charge how long it
should take you don't know any of the
things unless you know where you're
trying to go like for me I I don't have
like a question where I'm like hey like
is this helping me become the most of
this or the most of that I kind of think
about it because the reality is we have
multiple things right so if if Mark is a
realist is I got to be the is this good
for Rome well you know what about this
stuff for my son right yeah so I think
about it in terms of like I want to be
very good at my professional life I want
to be a great writer I want to be a
great husband and I want to be a great
father and those three things are
related but also in tension with each
other but the nice part about the
tension is it prevents you from going
too far in One Direction and I think it
it sort of forces a kind of discipline
there's things I could do that would
make me more successful as a writer but
would come at the cost of my marriage or
there's things uh like my wife and I
could do that would make our marriage
better but then you know we're
personally happier but we're gone all
the time or whatever right like you have
to think about how these things matter
to each other or balance with each other
and my friend Austin Cleon uh sent to me
once he said um actually right when I
moved to Austin he said work Family
scene pick two
so the point was you can be good at your
work you can have a family
but like partying being cool experience
like the fun experiences the perks of
the job you know you gotta say no to
that conversely you can be great at your
job and party it up but like you're
probably not going to find that person
or your kids are going to be like
where's Dad right so you can't have all
those things and and when you know okay
well the important things to me are work
and family are the important things are
family and having a good time okay well
you're gonna leave some potential some
your whatever your magnum opus is it's
not going to happen right and so knowing
that okay here's what I want and then
here's what what I'm willing to trade or
give up to that to get that thing you
know like that Clarity is super super
important what was that word a crazier
acrosia yeah the the idea that there's
sort of a higher self and a lower self
and these
it's sort of for the Ancients there was
this sort of perennial battle between
the higher self and the lower self and
you know discipline to me is
the deciding factor right mediate them
which wins right you know
what side of you is going to win out
here
and you know it takes a a sort of a
strength of will that the story I uh
that goes to the beginnings of stoicism
uh is the it's called the choice of
Hercules Hercules is walking through the
hills of Greece and he comes to this
Crossroads and basically there's two
goddesses one is the goddess of vice and
the other is the goddess of virtue you
know basically one is the lower self and
the higher self the easy way and the
hard way and he has to choose you know
he has to choose you get you know do you
get everything you want it's easier
you're willing to work for it are you
willing to sacrifice you know virtue or
advice that choice of Hercules was at
the essence of you know stoicism are you
are you choosing the disciplined way or
the ill-disciplined way uh you know
and that choice we we face that choice
not just like this one big pivotal
moment in our lives where you choose
between I'm gonna go for it or not go
for it like you said you you also choose
it every day I'm gonna eat this or that
am I going to get up at this time or
this time am I gonna push through when
it's hard or am I gonna wait for it to
be easy like that choice happens over
and over and over again the Stokes would
say that you know if you want to be
beautiful if you want to be great you
have to make beautiful or great choices
so it comes down to over and over again
we have this choice of Hercules and do
we make it often enough I don't I don't
know if you have to make it always but
more often than not you have to make
that right beautiful great choice and
that is what determines whether you will
be those things do you think there's a
risk of attaching a sense of self-worth
to your ability to be disciplined seems
to me that a lot of the friends that I
have who are superbly disciplined spend
more time lambasting themselves for
missing out by one to five percent on
the the perfect game for each day yeah
because the the meditation was good and
they did it but maybe they thought about
work for a minute of their 15-minute
meditation do you know what I mean it
makes you fragile well the Paradox of of
having high standards is that it makes
you
more likely to reach
Great Heights but also almost
constitutionally unable to enjoy or
appreciate or even recognize that that's
where you are right like the person who
goes oh that was the greatest game in
the world I crushed it
is you know not going to see all the
things they could have done better right
the person who goes oh but I messed up
this this and this
that person is 10 is going to be the one
is is going to tend to be the one that's
improving and growing and and and that's
good but it's also not a recipe for
happiness for contentment for
sustainability
Seneca is writing this letter to his
friend lucillius and and they're talking
about stosis and this idea that you know
you try to get better every day hold
yourself to these high standards you
know at this point he's probably in his
60s or 70s he's been doing this a long
time and he goes how do I know he's sort
of rhetorically but maybe lucillus had
asked him like how do you know you're
doing it right right and he goes how do
I know that I'm doing it right that I'm
getting better and he says I each day I
become a better friend to myself that's
how I know I'm making progress
and I think what he means is that
discipline or stoicism is not this
constant whipping of oneself this
constant feeling of falling short of not
being good enough being like you piece
of [ __ ] I hate you like look who could
have done all these things better but
it's a sense of like you did your best
good job I love you I respect you uh
there's still room to grow but there's
nothing you have to feel guilty or
terrible about and I think it's if you
want to do this well you want to do a
sustainably uh you have to understand
that discipline is not
form of self-flagellation it should not
be hurtful you should love it like in
meditations Marcus really says love the
discipline you know and let it support
you and I think he he means that
discipline in both senses he means the
philosophical discipline but he also
means like the practice of it and I
think that love and support are too like
operative but also
uh underrated words there right like it
if you feel bad about yourself and
that's what you think discipline is I
think you're getting it wrong it's a
motivating factor though right that's
where people do it they need to have
both keratin stick and for the most part
A lot of the people I think that are
seduced by heavy discipline they're
stick people a good example of this so
Andy frizzella who reached out a couple
of months ago he did that 75 hard thing
he was the guy that made 75 hard have
you heard of this no okay so it's a
challenge for 75 days in a row and you
have to do two 45 minute workouts read
10 pages of a non-fiction book
meditate uh drink a gallon of water do
something else and don't break your diet
it's something like that it's like a
list of things kind of basic but pretty
intense
and if you miss any one thing on any one
day of the 75 you go back to the start
and you start again and
from the outside I loved the idea I
haven't done it but I love the idea of
something that created a framework for
people to build discipline around
however I haven't got a single friend
that's done 75 hard and not snapped
afterward and not gone to a period of a
decrease in discipline even if you
smeared it across 150 days their
discipline overall is lower one of the
guys didn't train for half a year after
he did it one of the guys didn't
meditate another one of the dudes
couldn't bear to go into work and do a
bunch of other stuff because they just
myopically nailed themselves to this
goal and sustainable perseverance
commitment over time like these are the
sort of words I think that being
introduced into a more holistic view of
discipline would be interesting uh magic
words for me are more often than not
like more often than not are you doing
what you're supposed to be doing are you
uh holding yourself to high standards
are you taking the you know the the hard
Choice over the Easy Choice putting in
the extra more often than not are you
doing it right if you if you try to hold
yourself to this perfect or impossible
standard
um not only are you liable to sort of
not do it uh and then feel terrible
afterwards but I think it can so often
come at the expense of other things that
are important or it become you become so
terribly out of balance that it's almost
an excuse right you're like
so what you do some challenge for 30
days or 75 days or whatever it's like
they don't throw you a parade at the end
you know I mean look I I appreciate the
idea of challenging yourself pushing
ourselves into a certain degree all
discipline is arbitrary but like I'm not
trying to just win made up competitions
or check arbitrary you know things off
the list I I wanna I wanna do this
consistently over a long period of time
so I run it's one of the things that
happens when people when people find out
you're running they go oh are you
running a marathon are you training to
do an Iron Man I'm not trying to win at
my hobbies you know like the to me the
doing the thing
is the reason I'm doing it it's good for
me for a variety of reasons if I but but
it could very easily become an unhealthy
unproductive thing that comes at the
expense of the other things that are
important to me so I think sometimes
people can get caught up with
seeing it again as this kind of a means
to an end when it it should be
as sort of an integrated practice into
your life I think that this becomes very
prevalent when you grow up a little bit
that my ability to view broader time
Horizons has only really kicked in in
the last couple I'm 34 it's only kicked
in the last few years that you presume
the thing you're doing now is going to
be the way that life's going to be
forever and the training plan that you
do now even if there's a 10 20 risk of
injury over the next six months doesn't
matter because you want to be jacked to
go away in summer holiday or whatever
and then after a while you realize no my
goal is in 20 or 30 years to be
significantly more capable than I am now
yeah what is the route between me now
and me there and the fear and the um
degree of neuroticism around it being
well it's not fast enough it doesn't
happen quick enough that dissolves quite
nicely
I was talking to the Olympian uh Kate
Courtney she's this amazing mountain
bike racer and she was telling me you
know like her her coach would give her a
workout she's like you know ride 20
miles she ride 25 miles or you know do
it in two hours and she'd do it in 90
minutes
and I think a lot of successful driven
people understand that impulse like
you're like I want to win everything
right even practice
and he said to her once uh
and and when I signed her copy of
disciplines Destiny I wrote this in it
because I think about it all the time uh
he said do you want to be fast now or do
you want to be fast later
right the purpose of training the
purpose of practice is to peek in the
race in the moment that it matters
um life is a little bit different than
the Olympics is that it is no sort of
one moment but if you have this idea
that you know your big moment is in the
future that it's a marathon and not a
Sprint the idea of sort of forcing it
now peaking early is actually something
you should be quite worried about so you
have to be disciplined about your
discipline you have to curb that impulse
to do in some ways the easier thing now
which is like I want to go all out I
want to push everything into the center
of the table I want to go now but now
might not be the moment and the ability
to step back to restrain yourself to to
to to focus on sustainability and
endurance and all that you know if it's
May well be the harder thing and so it's
like do you want to be great now or do
you want to be ready when like a truly
great opportunity is there do you want
to do your best work at 22 or the only
work at 22 or do you still want to be
doing this when you're 82 because you
love it because you'll have more
experiences and wisdom and all that
stuff now and those are the kind of
questions I think people at a really
Elite level are thinking about what was
that comparison between Lou Gehrig's
Korea and Babe Ruth's career and how the
trajectories went well I mean clearly
Lou Gehrig and Babe Ruth are two of the
greatest baseball players of all time uh
both achieve incredible athletic Feats
but when you look at Lou gehrer when you
look at Babe Ruth you're sort of like
how like how did you even like he
doesn't look like an athlete and so in
some ways he's very impressive that he
could hit all these home runs but you
you definitely get the sense and and the
more I think you study uh you know sort
of Elite Performance to our history
sometimes you're just amazed
and saddened
at the greatness of someone because
you're like how did you do it and what
could you have been capable of if you
weren't Your Own Worst Enemy so both Lou
Gehrig and Babe Ruth's careers are cut
short right uh Lou Gehrig from Lou
Gehrig's Disease or ALS
and then Babe Ruth I mean this wasn't a
guy who took care of himself he burned
through millions of dollars he treated
his body like a garbage can you know he
sort of has this precipitous decline at
the end and you know he was not Tom
Brady right like in Peak uh athletic
conditioning at the end of his career he
was a obese you know uh drunk old man
right and
that's so tragic to me right and to me
the idea is like if you respect the
craft if you really love the thing
you're doing you owe it to that craft to
take the responsibilities of it
seriously right and I think
um I I wanted to show that contrast
because we so often just assume oh these
person accomplish all these things
therefore it's good but what else could
they have done had they had more
discipline and I think
one of the
small consolations of someone like Lou
Gehrig is you go
he left it all in the Jersey like there
was nothing that he could have done in
his career that he didn't do the only
thing that uh the only tragedy was that
for reasons that were not his fault he
didn't get to do it as long as he could
have done it right but the games that he
played he showed up for and he played
them and I think about that you know
every day when I wrap up I'm like did I
leave it all there or
that I phone it in today you know did I
uh make excuses today did I not bring my
best self to this thing
and again more often than not you want
the good answer to that question I like
the idea of the more often than not
because it means that an individual
repetition that is sub-optimal today I I
just didn't quite work
it seems like it would give you a little
bit more Detachment from it and I think
that that's very important yeah you Marx
released in meditation because you gotta
pick yourself up when you fall but also
celebrate that you're a human being and
none of us are perfect
that we're going to mess up we're going
to screw up but if you have this sort of
Baseline that you you know what you're
capable of you know what you should do
you know that you're not always going to
be able to do it but you know what to
come back to to me is more important
than having these impossible perfect
standards that are almost in their own
way
paralyzing or impossible or discouraging
and and so I think cultivating a kind of
like a rhythm that there's like this
thing and sometimes you sometimes you
fall off the Rhythm but you know how to
come back to it that to me is a a more
sustainable conscious
Kinder way to be committed to something
I think that again that's something that
you learn through experience I was
locked into perennially locked into a
work so hard that I can't take any more
burnouts spend three days in bed yeah it
worked so hard that was me that was that
was the cycle of how I worked pretty
much for most of my twenties one of the
advantages of doing that was that now I
know some of the warning signs when I
start to get close to that yeah and I
can just yeah and I can just about fly
underneath that a little and go okay how
long can I hold this for and I'll back
off a little bit more but it's less of
this yeah apart from the fact that it's
less efficient because three days of
doing nothing is a lot worse than a
couple of days of doing 50 of something
yeah but it's just
suffering the difference in terms of
suffering is pretty drastic and I think
another interesting example so you're
talking there about two different types
of athletes one of whom left everything
on the table another one who didn't and
you know took a turn away Michael Jordan
seems to be someone that was almost
tyrannical in the way that he went about
his game and left it all on the table
but did it in a way that sacrificed
everything else pretty much everything
else
do you think that it's possible for
people to get extreme results in life
whilst still having that balance it
seems like you're trying to to do that
and that was the two out of three uh
example to me that that's the challenge
like it's almost easier to be great than
it is to be good and I I don't mean to
contrast good and great in that sense I
mean that like like to say I don't care
about anything but succeeding in this
thing
is almost taking yourself off the hook
to a certain degree there's a a writer
when she said like I don't want to have
kids I don't want to get married I want
to be an art monster right and I get
that right I think anyone who's like
loves what they do there's a certain
like I want to be the center of
everything I only want this thing to
matter but that's almost the easier path
right like to to to be like well why is
this person an [ __ ] and they're like
well they're great you know like that
it's it's I think sometimes people think
that they're innate Talent or there's
success or their commitment to a path or
goal is like an exemption from
the rules of human behavior right I
don't have to care about other people I
don't have to keep my word I you know
there's a there's a story about this
writer I'm forgetting her name she was
at this party she had a young daughter
and uh she's a poet and she's at this
party in Jack Kerouac is there and she
you know it's one of those famous
parties and she's there and and uh
she gets up to leave she goes you know I
I am
I promise the babysitter I'd be home by
10 she has like a young daughter I have
to leave and Jack Kerouac you know sort
of a different model of the kind of
writer says you know if you don't forget
about that babysitter you'll never be a
great writer
and she gets up and she leaves anyway
and and she says later I knew in that
moment that if I didn't keep that
promise to the babysitter I wouldn't be
a great writer
and her point was that like
having some Talent some calling doesn't
exempt you from keeping your word and
then in fact if you tell the babysitter
you're going to be home at 10 and then
you blow that off you're also the kind
of person that says I'm going to be at
my desk riding by nine
and you break that promise also right
and so actually I think cultivating a
practice or a set of standards that are
more than just like how good are you
professionally makes you a more
well-rounded and better professional and
the people that I really admire are
people who have you know gotten to the
commanding Heights of their profession
but are still good neighbors and
citizens and activists and fathers or
daughters or wives like I I just there's
something to me Hollow and and kind of a
cop-out about being great at one thing
at the expense of all the other things
when
especially at the end of your life you
don't get to take that thing with you
you know you don't get to take it with
you so what does it matter that you made
more money or
you wrote one extra book like you're
gonna sit back and go I really [ __ ] it
up
that's why it's so important to start
with the end in mind I think why am I
doing this yes what are the ordinating
principles that I have yes that I'm
working toward because yeah you could
spend a very very long time climbing up
a ladder to find out that it's up
against the wrong wall yeah I mean and
how many people they're on the metal
stand you know they're accepting the
Nobel Prize or you know they they get to
that number they told themselves like I
want to make the and then
about Beyond mountains there's more
mountains yeah it's a Haitian proverb
behind Beyond mountains there are more
Mountains but I think it's more it's
more like you think that this thing is
going to fix it it's going to make me
feel good it's going to make my parents
proud of me it's going to make me part
of the club
we think that these external things are
going to address this internal
lacking or need or emptiness that we
have and
I
I've done a lot I've read a lot I've
talked to a lot of people I've yet to
find someone
that got it just it's a it's a mirage it
it's a phantom you get there and it
moves
and uh
in one sense that's a tragedy in the
other sense it's a great gift right the
first time you do that thing
and you get it the thing you've been
working for and then it isn't what you
thought it would be if in that moment
you can
accept the gift you've been given which
is a decoupling from external success
and internal contentment happiness
enoughness if you can make that break in
that moment you're free and empowered
forever because now you can still do the
things you're good at you still want
them but you you are no longer at the
whims of this lie or this delusion yes
uh but what most people do in that
moment is
tell themselves a second lie which is oh
it's
I have to prove I can win an NBA
championship on my own I have to show
that this wasn't a fluke oh it's not 10
million dollars actually it's a hundred
million dollars right or it's it's not
number two that's enough it's a gotta be
number one
um if that's what you do I think you
have it you have made a bargain or told
yourself a lie that is now almost
impossible
for you to get free of
I think that people need to see that for
themselves yes I've been told this
lesson a million times yeah and I each
time that something good happens that
feels like a success
it helps me to prove that same rule to
myself yes a little bit more yes uh
Robert writes why Buddhism is true in
that he talks about
um life is suffering said by the Buddha
and the word duka d-u-k-k-h-a contested
by some Scholars is not meaning
suffering but unsatisfactoriness life is
unsatisfactory in us and given that uh
Robert is a evolutionary psychologist
now writing about Buddhism that aligns
those two perfectly like humans are not
built to be happy we're built to be
effective and Effectiveness is
everything being just a bit more [ __ ]
than you thought it was going to be well
from an evolutionary perspective there's
very little value in the Finish Line
existing right there's a lot of
evolutionary value that is moving a
little bit further it's like the Horizon
you never actually get there but in
chasing it you go further and further
and further and so understanding why it
exists should help you yes Break Free of
the the power that it has over you and I
mean look I I've
liked to think that the work that I've
done since coming to this conclusion is
still very good right it's just and in
fact I would argue it's better like when
I think of
like
there's no question craving or anger or
wanting to prove something this is
powerful fuel
but at the same time it's very volatile
Fuel and I'm not sure it actually puts
you in the headspace needed to do like
your best work and I I would think that
the work that I've done from a place
more of fullness and contentment and
balance I think it's better like not
only is it better for me but I think the
actual product is better
um but I think people are really afraid
they're afraid of what it will cost
they're afraid of like if I put this
down if I'm motivated by something
different if I no longer need to do X Y
or Z I won't do it anymore
and so they don't so they find you know
the anger gets them here and then
they're like well I need to find
something new to be angry about or you
know I shoved it in these people's faces
and it wasn't as satisfactory as I
thought so I'm gonna shove it in more
people's face right and that that is
again from an evolutionary perspective
from an output perspective it's it it
works but I'm not actually sure it's
best but it's also what are you
optimizing for again if it's a miserable
experience and if you sacrifice the
thing that you want to achieve the thing
which is supposed to get the thing that
you want if you sacrifice happiness in
order to become successful so that you
can finally be happy yeah it's that
story of the fisherman again like well
just just why not just be happy why not
just give yourself a little bit more of
a break yeah you talk to people and
you're like well why do you want to do X
and they're like then I can do why and
why is so much more accessible to them
now and why
why do you think they're mutually
exclusive I'm not sure that they are
I mentioned Queen Elizabeth earlier on
what did you learn about her
well I think she's this remarkable
person I mean you look at someone you
don't talk about sustainability you have
this job for 70 years and you know as I
was saying the idea of Market Street is
given these privileges this immense
Power Platform
Etc
and he proves himself worthy of it I
mean look at the outpouring of support
for this woman when she died even from
people who have sort of an ideological
disagreement with the monarchy to me
that's very high praise when people who
disagree with what you do still find the
way that you did it to be admirable and
impressive and you know
she was a remarkable picture of
restraint and dignity and poise
tradition but also flexibility and
Innovation and I I just you know
discipline is not just how far can you
run you know how hard can you work it's
also you know
are you in control of yourself like you
talk you want to talk about someone who
was in command of themselves
this is a woman who over 70 years never
lets the mask slip never has the
Outburst never has the you know dropping
for 70 years she's like on point for a
thing that she didn't choose for a thing
that you know
only because of a
Quirk of History even was in a position
to take tell people that story in case
they're not familiar so uh uh her uncle
was the King of England uh he abdicates
in this sort of fit of passion as he's
in love with this terrible woman
basically uh and suddenly Queen
Elizabeth's father becomes king you know
he would have been expected to rule for
20 30 40 years instead sort of dies I
think after like 20 25 years
her father dies unexpectedly young of
lung cancer and then in her what late
20s early 30s is I think yeah early 20s
is suddenly the queen of of this
enormous Empire uh
and what is her job you know her job is
better defined by all the things she's
not allowed to do as opposed to the
things that she can do it's this
symbolic role and you know I wanted to
illustrate the idea of discipline again
it's not just but it's also when you
feel like er and not doing it right the
restraint and Poise uh the the ability
to to want to do something to very
understandably want to do something and
then to not do it because it's not
the right thing to do that becoming yeah
queenly that that that is a kind of
discipline and Grace that I think we
need to see more of you know we think
about
you're like why is this person tweeting
this why are they saying this why are
they doing this and you're like well
they can you know
not because it's the right thing to do
not because it's important not because
it's going to accomplish X Y and Z but
this kind of lack of self-control I
think she's a she is a
inspiring picture of what self-control
can look like and not not self-control
in the masculine sense which is what we
I think we so often tend to stereotype
it as
how would it be feminine
well I just mean like she's she's not
this isn't a physical thing this is a
spiritual and emotional and a mental
thing yeah as you're getting these
headlines written about you that are
claiming you think a thing or did a
thing or a part of a thing and you don't
have the compulsion to write a response
to what is it like she's a she was a
little old lady you know and that it
she's not this big hulking thing she's a
little old lady and yet
you know was more restrained and
disciplined than these ambitious Prime
Ministers male or female right like she
she had a sort of a different path to
power and in a world where everyone says
everything that they think
and is constantly fighting for their
recognition for their chance in the
spotlight I mean she's a really powerful
example or was a really powerful example
that the opposite of those things is
often more impressive or a better path
didn't
Martin Luther King get punched by a Nazi
or something and it was that's kind of a
similar situation yeah yeah again uh we
tend to think of discipline it's
strength Force
um there's a moment uh in Martin Luther
King's career he's obviously a committed
proponent of non-violence and it's it's
one thing to be like strategically we
are Marching from here to there the
police are going to attack us we just
need to keep going you know he's on
stage in a in a Nazi uh walks on stage
and just
starts punching him in the face in front
of everyone that he knows and what
people said they found so so he's
attacked so first you know he's hit and
the natural human thing when you're hit
would be to protect yourself which he
does instinctively hits himself and
people said the shocking sound like the
auditorium goes dead silence you can
just hear you know Flesh on flesh
and then there's this moment so he's you
know he's being tested at the highest
level he's I am a practitioner of
non-violence
um that doesn't mean I don't just not
engage in violence but like what do you
do when you are violently attacked
and in this Split Second as he protects
himself he catches himself and they said
he drops his hands
and it was like this you know it's this
is more than self-discipline this is
some higher almost saint-like place that
he's managed to reach where you know
again he's not just protecting himself
not defending like not actively
defending himself but he is
for philosophical and spiritual reasons
that the discipline is to actually allow
yourself to be attacked in this moment
which it does
um and you know it was this shocking
moment that sort of fundamentally it
teaches the power of non-violence and
that his commitment to the message more
than any other thing he could have
possibly done
um and and then you know obviously the
man is swarmed and the first words out
of Martin Luther King's mouth are like
don't it don't hurt him don't hurt him
and again it's easy to say these things
but then what do you do in that moment
of being tested and to me it that's more
impressive than you know any Olympic
gold medalist or you know feat of
athletic strength that he's able to
conquer his like almost
innately human
need to protect yourself he's able to
stop that in the moment that that to me
is you know disciplined at some sort of
transcendent heroic level what about
perseverance what did you learn about
people who coped when things got really
difficult it seems to me that discipline
even in the modern world you know no
matter how hard it is that you're
working toward a thing and how difficult
the pursuit is it's still quite a
Bourgeois sort of luxurious position to
be in you know we I know that you
recently got a cold tub we've got one
and got one in the house as well uh
let's not get that wrong we are laughing
at discomfort sure we're electing to go
into discomfort because the world has
become so nerfed and so comfortable
around us that we need to buy pieces of
kit that we can get into that forces to
feel cold what about times where do you
stand where can people find that's firm
for them to stand when they're doing the
discipline and the world just continues
to punch them in the face
yeah I mean I I wouldn't I wouldn't be
so quick to dismiss
the difficulties of
life right like uh I think it's good to
have practices physical practices that
push us but like life is [ __ ] hard
and it breaks your heart the there's
Murphy's Law right what can't go wrong
will there's also another law that says
like it always takes longer than you
expect even when you take this law into
account right like it's hard like people
go I want to start a podcast
how long it took you before you even
started to see Rewards or it pay off
like I mean even just now you're
probably early in it right it takes
longer than you think it's [ __ ] hard
and it breaks your heart you know
um is that is it certainly preferable to
like starving to get to death and some
you know desert plane of course right
um it's better than it's better you know
here in this moment than anywhere in
history probably anywhere in the world
of course but like
if you don't have a sort of a forge who
the Stokes call it an inner Citadel kind
of a fortress that you can Retreat into
uh that that you can rely on I said I
don't think you're gonna make it maybe
maybe algorithmically you get lucky and
it always goes your way maybe but to
count on that or to let alone expect
that you know I think is to
is to set yourself up to be crushed by
what is inevitably a heartbreaking
difficult you know
soil testing process Paul Graham talks
about
after the rush of the excitement of an
idea because of like the tech crunch
bump right you get your first bit of
attention then you enter the trough of
despair
right and the trough of Despair is
[ __ ] real like every book I start it
starts off exciting it's fun here's what
I'm gonna do and then right into the
trough of Despair and you might not come
out of that for months like and by the
time you're out of it
you don't even it catches oh I'm on the
downhill side of this like I'm you don't
even realize that you're out of it until
you're so far out of it that
that you're almost surprised by it so
you have to have this ability to endure
to show up [ __ ] every day even though
it's hard even though it doesn't feel
like you're making progress even though
not doing it would be way easier you
have to cultivate that strength and it
doesn't matter if it's you know you're
trying to become a massage therapist or
you're writing that you know some some
like you know the the Great American
novel like it's [ __ ] hard or you're
starting some movement you know you're
trying to build this movement off the
ground uh from nothing to change the
world like it's going to take a long
time things are going to constantly go
wrong it's going to be way harder than
you think and it might not test you in
the sense in the way that like starving
tests you but it's gonna challenge you
in every conceivable way and you have to
have
you have to have what it takes to get
through and you have to have a really
strong why too or you're not going to
get through it one of the other elements
that gets laid on top is I think shame
and guilt around it not being as bad as
it could be you know the fact that a lot
of the people that do deal with
discomfort it's them choosing to go
after a Pursuit that they care about
you're choosing to write these books no
one is holding a gun to your head other
than your own existential conscience
that you have to go and write these
books so okay well what what does that
mean how do I ameliorate the fact that
I'm I'm choosing to do a thing I'm
electing to do it but it's causing me
suffering but I also the suffering from
that I derive meaning and on the it's
sort of all this big mess I think you
know it's weird like as I wrote this
book several years ago called the
obstacles away and so people will go
like well what was the biggest obstacle
in your life and I think people think
it's like some contest or this measuring
thing or or they think that
the only obstacles that count are like
well I lost my leg in an accident when I
was seven or you know I was born it you
know and barely survived this genocidal
attack like obviously all those things
are profound obstacles and we can learn
so much from Victor Frankel and man
search for me they're these people who
have been through the absolute like
Crucible of The Human Experience and
they have something profoundly deep and
Powerful to teach us
but I think we're often quick to dismiss
the adversity of Our Lives you know and
and we somehow think also that it's this
thing that happens once and in fact we
all wake up every single day in a world
that we don't control that's utterly
indifferent to us our happiness our you
know fulfillment and the challenge is
like do you have what it takes to keep
going through that to not be despite to
not despair you know uh to not become
cynical to to keep believing to keep
trying to keep pushing to keep
using the experiences that you have to
to to get better to me that's that's the
marathon of it that's the gauntlet of it
and I I'm just uh of course we should
poke fun at the fact that we live these
Nerf lives and we should acknowledge
readily the incredible privileges that
we have compared to other people
compared to people who lived a long time
ago but if if you think that it's easy
because we're privileged or because you
know you're not uh running from you know
somebody trying to kill you you're
I think being naive and anyone who's
done anything hard can tell you like you
have many moments these sort of Dark
Nights of the Soul moment and if you
don't have something to draw on uh
you're you're not going to get through
that well what's a firm place for people
to stand then you know you're doing
something you're working hard and it's
just difficulty after difficulty the
discipline is being tested
where do they where do they go in those
moments yeah I mean the the for the
Stokes that's what the inner Citadel was
this sort of the the principles the
ideas the the the the the practices that
you've gone that where you go hey I've
been through tough [ __ ] before right
like uh I've been through stuff like
this before I mean just to think if you
just think about first off the
unlikeliness of you and I even being
here we're already extremely lucky
um but you think about like you were
born this tiny defenseless thing with no
discernible skills or knowledge and
you're not [ __ ] dead like you you you
you you survived against incredible odds
and incredible adversity to even like
you learned how to walk you know you got
through school this like
crazy insane you know
thing you worked your way up from like
nothing like in that sense like it's an
incredible journey just as like someone
who who you know went from poverty to
wealth they'd be like I got from here to
there like we all have the ability to
look back and be like look at where I
was not that long ago right and you
should you should have some sense of
what you're capable of Marcus Rio said
meditations he goes like
what is sort of worried or anxious about
some
future thing and he goes well what will
I meet that with and he says the same
tools that I've met today with like that
you you have been through stuff and
especially coming out of the pandemic
like people should go like you just live
through
a historical event of you know Epic
Proportions in the way that you would
hear from grandparents who lived through
the depression or the war you know
traveled across oceans on some boat to
go to some new like those historical
moments are on par with the historical
moment that we just lived through that
we are continuing to live through and
you're still here and I'm not I'm not
implying the people who are not here
somehow not here as a result of their
own but what I'm saying is like
you have been you have been in the arena
and you have been knocked around and you
you made it and you should be able to
look back at the things that you've done
and take have a certain pride and
confidence in your ability to get
through real [ __ ] and that should give
you some firm ground to stand on as you
contemplate what tomorrow might bring
you know like you'll meet tomorrow with
what you met yesterday with and what
you've met all the challenges of your
life with and I mean I do think there's
value in seeking out difficulties and
challenges and pushing yourself so you
you have even more confidence but like
the fact that you're here that you've
been through all the things you've been
through that's not nothing yes I love
that uh the the idea of the inner
Citadel is you're talking away I've got
this idea of a huge grand hall maybe
influenced by the fact I'm watching a
lot of Game of Thrones at the moment a
huge grand hall and above the fireplace
or all of the heads of the different
enemies but they're all you it's all you
at different stages it's all it was you
when you doubted your ability to do this
it's you when you felt weak and you
decided you're going to do it anyway
it's you when you chose the path that
was virtuous as opposed to the one that
was hedonic uh I have a friend
um who I saw at the start of this week
and his band has a lyric that says I
can't drown my demons they've learned
how to swim and he'd suffered with
depression same as me throughout his 20s
and that's one of the things that was
one of the most empowering enlightening
Reflections I had from dealing with
depression for a chunk of time was the
world is going to have to do really
really well to be able to torture me
more than my own mind already did like I
have already become the
prison keeper of every single little bit
that I knew was exactly the like uh
pharmaceutical grade yeah insult that I
wanted that was pinpoint accurate to
make me feel as bad as possible and each
different time that you get past that
another head goes up on the wall another
head goes up on the wall that's another
situation that I've managed to get
myself through when I was adamant that
it was going to be destruction and and
embarrassment and all the rest of it and
everybody that's listening is listening
and that's that's the benefit also of
discipline and having high standards
which is like you know that what you
subject yourself to on a regular basis
the standards you hold are higher than
the other things you're not intimidated
by like what are other people gonna
think how's it going to do because you
have worked
to such a degree that that's all that is
almost like settling that's like the low
end of what you're expecting yes and you
know this difference I think between
kind of an inner score card and an outer
score the outer scorecard's almost the
easier one like what do other people
think do people like me you know
obviously it's not under control but
there's a there's a
there's a softness to that because it's
it's it may well be less than you're
actually capable of yes
yes what about um Eisenhower's smoking
habit what do you learn from that well
we're talking about this guy who says
you know freedom is the opportunity for
self-discipline is this most powerful
man in the world and he's in his 50s or
60s and he has these heart problems in
the doctor because dude it's the smoking
man you've been smoking you know five
packs a day or whatever for 30 years
and he gives himself an order and he
quits right he just quits cold turkey
after a lifetime of a habit which is
extremely difficult to do
and you know I think the stoics were
very
suspicious of anything that
was in control of us
so Seneca says you know show me someone
who isn't a slave you know the slave to
a mistress or to fame or to money or to
what other people think
and you know he wanted to
he wanted to break any of those habits
right to to to rule he's a ruling over
the self is the greatest Empire and you
know are you in charge of the cigarettes
are you in charge of the phone are you
in charge or the need to win one more or
make more or can't pass up the deal I
can't be out of the thrill you know are
you in charge or is the need in charge
and they
when the need was in charge that was
something you needed to look very very
hard at
if you need any substance in order to
perform then it stopped conferring a
benefit that's the reason why I did a
thousand days sober even though I wasn't
drinking that much but I was like look I
am going to be the person that gets to
call the shots yeah uh I'm gonna go out
on nights out and I'm gonna work out
what it's like to go on a night out so
but as a club promote there's a [ __ ]
club promoter for like 15 years and then
I did 500 days without caffeine and I
think that caffeine stairs people in the
face I think that most people don't have
varying levels of tiredness they simply
have varying levels of caffeine
concentration in their blood people
don't say I'm tired they say I need a
coffee you've supplanted the problem for
the solution sure the way that you
describe it and what happens is by doing
that I'm using
chemicals as a proxy for everything else
here but you paper over the cracks
that are causing that to come through
have you ever stopped to think about why
you're so [ __ ] tired at two o'clock
in the afternoon right like is it maybe
that you're not actually getting enough
sleep is it that you're going to bed at
different times is it that you're
sleeping the wrong things or exactly
yeah of course yeah you got to look at
the sort of root cause yeah and and any
time
you can't not do a thing
you probably need to stop doing that
thing and that and this is this is true
for work too right like if you're like I
just can't be out of it like I can't
stop
uh workaholism there you know there's
there's the addictions or the
compulsions that are not socially
acceptable
you know heroin uh you know
and then there's the ones that
are not just socially acceptable but
often socially rewarded and those are
the those are the most Insidious ones
and you know people will applaud you for
and they'll celebrate and then they'll
they'll laugh at you or question you or
make you feel like you're the crazy one
for not doing it why don't you want to
go out with us well I don't enjoy doing
that
um
and then you feel like a weirdo for
having your sort of own thing that you
don't want to do and yeah it requires
discipline because I'm not not
interested the same for you with the
books I mean I imagine that you're
writing close to the limit in terms of
what you could write but if you someone
had a gun to your head you would be able
to crack out another however many
percent per day so there is some that's
being left in the tank there is a little
bit that's being left in the tank with
regard with regards to that so the well
why don't you want more success that
would be more Accolade that would be
more Applause that would be the
Publishers would be [ __ ] delighted
I'm sure so well the question when they
when they try to see it is something you
know someone an addict or you know
someone have does it someone have a
problem it's you know
what are the costs of this thing to you
where are there negative repercussions
in your life from this thing right and
so if it's coming at the expense of X Y
and Z so yeah sure I could do more I
could do more faster but it would it
would start to deteriorate the quality
of the other things that are important
to me or it might
shrink the time Horizon that I the the
longevity that I would like to have and
so yeah you have to ask yourself is is
trying to do it now or trying to do it
later or you know um
well what's what's actually important to
me what about the cautionary tales from
people like Napoleon and King George IV
because I have I no background about
either of these people well I tell the
story in the book about Napoleon he
writes this essay as a young man about
the Perils of ambition you know he says
what is Alexander doing trying to make
it to the ends of the Earth you know he
can't he's conquering this and this and
this
um and he goes like what a fool you know
so the irony that you know he would then
be that conqueror
it's almost too perfect
um but it's what happens right none of
those people start off thinking that's
where I'm going to end up it's a process
that once you begin it's it's hard to
stop and yet like once that Governor
comes off it's almost
inevitable right and ambition is a thing
talking about socially acceptable
addictions
ambition is a thing that very few people
question or criticize
up until
it stops working right
everyone's clapping you on the back
telling it's a great idea right up until
you overreach and lose all of it and
then they go you're a fool what were you
thinking how could you do it
and so you have to have that sense no
other people
consequences of your life all these
things they're going to be the lagging
indicators you've already passed the
point of no return so you have to have
this sort of internal Governor this
internal compass
this internal sense of your limitations
that uh you know prevents you from
becoming another cliche and what about
King George Well King George I I was
sort of contrasting him to
do you want the the life where you say I
don't eat this this is how hard I have
to work out this is you know the
strenuous life seems like the hard life
right compared to eat what I want I do
what I want
but who's happier right the person who's
in good shape or the person who's
not in good shape uh
the thing about you know exercise and
diet is that it's it it's hard now but
the Rewards or the the place it gets you
is is Pleasant
the thing about the Oreos or the
milkshake or you know whatever it is is
it feels good on the way down but the
the consequences are you know they
linger was that King George lab 1800s
was he East India Trading Company time
uh he's not he's not like the American
King George yes I think he's after that
King George too many Georgians this is
Queen Victoria's father I believe okay
so this might be about the right time
I'm watching uh taboo at the moment so
it's a five-year-old uh secretary Uncle
I forget with Tom Hardy in it yeah right
and it's all about the East India
Trading Company and and Tom Hardy comes
back and he's been in Africa and he's
learned voodoo magic and loads of other
stuff and uh it's got I would be very
surprised if it's not but he's got this
sort of big bloated like super fat king
and he's gout and a sort of bad
complexion and all this sort of stuff
and uh yeah I mean you you look at that
and Tom Hardy's this guy who is
continually sort of underfoot he keeps
on making the right decisions whenever
he can and you do you you are contrasted
between there's another guy that's kind
of an echo in between both of them and
the guy that has the life that you would
want to lead is probably Tom Hardy is
the guy that's actually doing the right
things
I sent you or I think I mentioned to you
the last time that we spoke about the
Forgotten Highlander yeah
how did you get on with that it was
fascinating uh it was fascinating uh
yeah when we talked about people who've
been through real adversity right
there's there's those levels to this guy
yeah yeah of course there there is some
level where you're like how is that even
humanly possible how did you not break
under these circumstances and it it
should remind you I think I mean one of
the things I take from that is that like
we're capable of more than we could
possibly conceive of so
when you're having that Dark Night of
the Soul you're in the trough of Despair
like
you can definitely make it through this
like you definitely have what it takes
to do this like we you come from an
unbroken line of those ancestors
right like
every one of us comes from an unbroken
line of people who endured Terrible
Things uh who made it through famines
and wars and
uh you know adversity and challenges
that we can't even begin to conceive of
and like
we should feel we should remind
ourselves that we're their descendants
you know we are The Heirs to that
tradition and you know to go back to the
idea about Marx Realtors are you going
to prove yourself worthy of it or are
you going to be it disappointment I to
me that's a that's a question to ask
yourself and some challenging moment
Ryan holiday ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the stuff that
you're doing at the moment was best to
go dailystoke.com I do one email every
day about Stoke philosophy and if you
like podcasts obviously do I do a
podcast version of it uh totally for
free every day at the daily story
podcast Ryan I appreciate you thanks for
having me what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]